the first operation underway to free U.S
civilians trapped in conflict-ridden
Sudan right now several hundred
Americans are preparing to sail to
safety more than 500 people have been
killed and thousands wounded since two
rival military factions began battling
for control of the capital two weeks ago
the fierce fighting has led to a
full-fledged Exodus from Africa's third
largest country CBS News has confirmed
those Americans left the capital of
Khartoum Friday in a convoy of 18 buses
embarking on a drive that took over 12
hours to the coast while confirmed the
under top cover protection likely from
U.S military drones next the plan is to
sail them across the Red Sea to Jetta in
Saudi Arabia CBS News foreign
correspondent Remy inasencio is standing
by in Jetta Remy good morning
good morning Jeff that's right and from
Sudan's Coast they will take another
12-hour journey across the Red Sea a
stretch of about 200 miles until they
arrive here at this Naval Port the ship
right behind me actually just docked a
few hours ago with nearly 2 000 evacuees
from Sudan today and the source that CBS
has been talking to about that American
evacuation says that there are more than
500 U.S civilians that are now currently
being processed but they are fleeing a
conflict that erupted exactly two weeks
ago today this is between the country's
military and its strongest paramilitary
force known as the rapid support forces
the two actually used to be allies they
overthrew a dictator in 2019 then
overthrew a joint civilian military
government in 2021 but now they are
targeting each other to try to protect
their own base of power tragically more
than 500 people have been killed in the
fighting more than 4 000 have been hurt
and access to Food Water hospitals the
internet have all just crumbled Sudan
was just taking its first steps to
democracy in just the past few years now
we are witnessing what really is a
meltdown in civil society and that is
why Americans Brits Canadians French
Japanese Chinese and so many people in
Sudan have been trying to get out
including Sudanese with dual nationality
we will get these stories to you
especially those from Americans as soon
as we talk to them as soon as they land
here in Jeddah Michelle
thank you